i get comments left and right garyvee  you say the same [ __ ] and i'm like  that's right [ __ ] because i  believe it because it's the thing to say  i said the same [ __ ] to my father this  weekend at vidcon that i've been saying  for 37 years and he told me this time it  clicked by show of hands how many people  here the first time they ever saw me  thought i sucked that was a scam artist  a piece of [ __ ] raise your hands raise  them high how many people that just  raised their hands were affected  positively by a piece of content in  their lives that's it that's the game if  you can go from this guy's a piece of  [ __ ] scam artist too this person  positively affected me that is only  required and can only be achievable when  you only talk about things you know and  you're willing to say them 87 000  different ways most people get caught up  because they feel like they've already  said their thing and they just start  making up some other [ __ ]